Ukraine is not alone.
And Ukraine will never be alone.
Putin might think that he can outlast us,
but he is wrong.
We stand with you today,
tomorrow, and for as long as it takes.
Cause this war
is about Ukraine's right to defend itself
and to determine your own future.
And the Ukrainian people's historic choice
to be an independent democracy at the heart of Europe.
Your quest for freedom
has inspired and moved the British people
and for the free nations of the world.
A to Ukraine
is also an investment in our own collective security.
Because if Putin wins in Ukraine,
he will not stop there.
And our opponents around the world
believe that we have neither the patience
nor resources for long wars.
So Weaver now,
and we embolden not just Putin,
but his allies in North Korea,
Iran and elsewhere.
That's why the United Kingdom and the free world
will continue to stand with Ukraine
as we have since the very beginning of this war.